and here we can see the
result of doing that.
For the first term, the standard basis state
of the top qubit is 0, so f of zero gets XORed
onto the bottom qubit,
and that works by linearity. And it's similar for the second term, except that the standard basis state
for the top qubit is 1, so we XOR f of 1 onto the bottom qubit.
And at this point, we can
simplify this expression by observing the formula
that you can see down here, which works when a is either 0 or 1.
And we can simply check this for those two values separately.
If a is equal to 0, then
XORing with a does nothing, and negative 1 to the power 0 is 1,
so the two sides are equal. And if a is equal to 1, we get cat 1 minus cat
0 when we take the XOR,
which is negative 1
times cat 0 minus cat 1.
And if we use that formula
to simplify our state, where we take a is equal
to f of 0 on the left and a is equal to f of 1 on the right,
we get the expression
that you see right here.
So when we compare the two
quantum state vectors π1 and π2, we see that what the Uf gate does
is effectively to put
one of the two values, f of 0 or f of 1, into the
exponent of negative 1,
or in other words, into
the phase of each term.
This is the reason for
initializing the bottom qubit to 1 and performing a Hadamard gate on it to create the minus state,
which allows this to happen.
It's called the phase kickback phenomenon, and we'll come back to it in a few moments to have another look at it.
It's pretty important, and we'll see it happening a
few more times in the lesson, as well as in later lessons.
We can now simplify by pulling
the minus state back outside to get the expression
that you see right here.
As an aside, it's kind
of interesting to notice that there isn't actually
any entanglement here.
Both of these states are product states. So, well, entanglement
is extremely interesting,
doesn't happen to be
playing any role at all in this particular algorithm.
Let's clean this up a bit so that we have a little bit more room.
What we can now do is to
pull a factor of negative 1 raised to the power f of zero outside
to get the expression of the
state that you see right here.
You'll notice that right here, we have eXclusive OR of f 0 and f 1 in the exponent of negative 1.
We might expect that to
be f of 1 minus f of 0 because we pull the factor of negative 1 to the power f of 0 out,
but we get the same
value if we take the XOR because these are bits, and the only thing that matters when we have an integer in
the exponent of negative 1
is whether that integer is even or odd.
Another way to express this
state is like we have here, where we're just considering
the two possible cases for the XOR.
and that's a convenient
way to express the state as we consider the action
of the final Hadamard gate together with the measurement.
When we perform the last
Hadamard gate on the top qubit, the plus state is
transformed into a 0 state
and the minus state is
transformed into a 1 state, which we can write more
succinctly like this.
And finally, when the
measurement is performed, the result we obtain is
therefore the XOR of f 0 and f 1,
which is the value we're looking for, and that's how Deutsch's algorithm works.
It's pretty simple, and if we ask ourselves what
it is that makes it work, allowing us to compute
the parity of two bits
with a single query rather than two, a reasonable answer is
that it's interference.
We're effectively
computing f of 0 and f of 1 at the same time, because we first performed
the Hadamard gate
on the top qubit to put the input into f into
a super position of 0 and 1.
And by means of the phase kickback together with the final Hadamard gate, we're essentially creating
constructive interference
for the correct answer and destructive interference
for the wrong answer.
So we don't see the wrong answer, we only see the correct answer.
Let me now say a bit more about the phase kickback phenomenon just to see it from a
slightly different angle.
First, let's observe
this very simple formula where b and c are arbitrary binary values.
In short, XORing a bit b by the value 1 is the same thing as performing a NOT gate or an x operation on b,
and of course, exploring
a bit b by the value 0 doesn't do anything to it, which is the same thing as performing the
identity operation on it.
And we can express the identity operation as x to the power 0.
So if we perform a Uf gate on two qubits in the standard basis
state cat b tensor cat a,
we obtain this outcome, just by the definition of the Uf gate.